all right monique and kyle
monique and kyle uh where you guys from
where you where you from originally i'm
from uh boston massachusetts
originally and monique and i am from
van nuys california
and uh
how how did you grow up you had mom and
dad
mom
yes i had my mother no father no
how would you describe your childhood
i
first came to my chaotic
i had a lot of siblings
it was never
lonely
it was always like i said chaotic
fun
good times
no abuse or anything
yeah
yeah i did experience watching my mother
get abused by different boyfriends
and verbal abuse as well on the children
you know myself and my siblings are
seven of us oh right now
and kyle how was your childhood
it was pretty good for the most part i
grew up with my mom
it was just me my mom for a while and my
stepdad came into the picture but
growing up with just my mom i thought it
was normal
and then like when my stepfather came to
the picture
i i thought he was my real dad um
i didn't know like the difference
between step dad and dad like
until i was 18 my mom told me that he
wasn't my one of my mom my cousin told
me that my [ __ ] my stepfather wasn't my
real dad
and that's when [ __ ] started getting
kind of chaotic
i started trying i started asking
questions like who's my dad
but um
yeah i graduated high school i played
baseball my whole life and i'm a big
sports guy in baseball
i love it but
as soon as i um as soon as i dipped in
the into the
drug world
well i lost everything okay what age did
that happen
17 16 16 17.
those are your friends that introduce
you to it or
yeah um
like in high school in like middle
school and high school like i got
bullied a lot because
i
got just i had to you know
my learning was a little slower than
everybody else's
so i got bullied for it and um
[Music]
because of that i had to find friends
that were
that i kind of fit in with and that
would have my back
and the group of friends that i found
were people that were doing drugs
and
that's that
i just never split up from them did you
finish high school i finished high
school
you came out to l.a
i came out to la for four and a half
years ago
i chased him i chased the girl from that
i that i met back home
i chased her out here and
[Music]
had a baby
and i relapsed i was sober when we
had our baby
and i relapsed when my son was four
months old
and um
the uh the the people they were gonna
come take him away from me said they
were gonna come take him away from me
and my baby mama
if i stayed around because i was the
only one using drugs so i had to go
homeless and that's when i became
homeless in california and i just never
i just never got back on track
what is your drug now
i i i smoke fit and all i know i
injected heroin for 14 years
and i graduated to fit you know
only because it's cheaper
and it's easier to get easier to get for
sure
monique how did you
how did your life go after you left home
um
leaving home wasn't
so hard i guess because i was always in
the streets as a child you know running
the streets with my brother my sister
but um
at 12 i started drinking you know it
would be like a shot or two for
christmas
new year's or whatever you know and
i like the way it made me feel i felt uh
superior i guess like i felt like
invincible you know the liquid courage
i was always outgoing but that made it a
little bit better you know i was a
tomboy i could hang out with anyone
really the tough crowd
um but after i let i left i was in and
out you know i was always getting kicked
out or just leaving because i didn't
want to be there i'm not really good
with authority or rules
um
but uh
yes i didn't i really became an
alcoholic when i was like
21 up until like my mid late 20s
and then i
started doing cocaine at like 25
and then i liked that a lot i would do
like the alcohol cocaine and xanax you
know all together
and that just became
much you know i was wild and mean i was
really i was a mean drunk very like
vulgar and disrespectful to my
family
more so than anyone which is odd
because they say that you hurt the ones
that you're closest to right that you
can get away with too and then when you
wake up because you're not gonna they'll
forgive you eventually i don't think
your mom's really gonna put you in jail
right away when you punch her in the
chest to get your car keys back you know
i've gotten two
duis uh
which
i've taken care of all that now but yeah
and
so i became really bad with that with
the mixture of those three drugs and i
took myself to rehab
you know
and i got off everything and i
met
kyle in rehab and they always say you
know those relationships don't work out
you need some time at least a year you
know sober
but we
we've been together since then and um
i lost my kids during the time i was
drinking so i lost them
but they're with the family
i have four boys now but then i only had
three
three boys
i started doing did you did you lose one
of your children
i i didn't lose them but they i mean i
still have would you say you had four i
had three and i lost them to the system
oh i see yes
and then we had a baby not too long
after we met
but around that time when i was still
drinking before i went to rehab
or after i think it was before i went to
rehab like i went downhill
you know when they take the kids away
you're supposed to get better
do classes parenting classes and you
know stuff like that
but that was a little much on my life
especially if i had to get a job and
stuff i can't go to a job so i have to
need this day and this time but it was
hectic it was really hectic and i went
downhill and
so that's when i went to rehab i met him
and i graduated after 60 days
and
i started doing meth in the streets
because of the drug he was on i wanted
to
the heroin i wanted to stay up and make
sure that i could watch over him so that
he wasn't dying you know in my hands
and i stayed with him in the streets
because i didn't want him to be alone
i thought
in my head that that would be the worst
way to go out is to look around and see
no one with you in a tent and in the
cold you know
so i stuck i i started using meth
around the age of 32 3132 and i've been
doing it since
so i could say it has been a downhill
battle but i've become very humbled to
the experience of being homeless
and
you know the knowledge of the heroin use
because my father was heroin addict
and he died from it he caught a hep c
and aids but the heps he killed him
so i now wish that i would i i now wish
that i'm able to i could have at least
talked to him about and say that i
understand rather than being so upset
with him
do you feel like it's a
genetic thing that you may have
inherited from him i've it's definitely
genetics because my mom's side of the
family
they've all been on methamphetamine
and
my father's side they've all been on
drugs my aunts some aunts from that side
as well as my father
my sister also
you know my my siblings we we use
so
a lot of your families
a lot of my family has been on on drugs
yeah and you know
i don't think they're ashamed and i and
i'm not really ashamed to say it it's an
experience in life and a lot of people
go through it no one's better than the
next and
i could say with a
i could say honestly with straight face
that i'm not ashamed of the drug use
it's just another stepping stone to the
rest of my life wherever that'll be
would you guys describe yourself as
happy
we're happy
it's definitely hard
it's really hard
it's like a hot happy
i think we can yeah it is a hard happy
i think we could definitely be happy if
we cut a lot of
the outside world out of our lives
because he
he tends to go based off a lot of what
people think you know um
he's very closed
and i'm more of like an open book a
social butterfly he's like the calm to
my storm
he's the calm to my storm and
sometimes i need i i mean i really do
need him to
be like you know stop
because i can be a little wild and
being homeless you can't really trust
everyone it's hard out in the streets
and for me it's hard for me to tell
who's who sometimes because i'm so
loving and caring and like oh my god i
want to help everyone
is it hard being a couple of romantic
couple
on the streets yes definitely especially
when you're both good looking
yeah no you guys are both handsome
thank you i can imagine
you're gonna get into it yeah he's
gorgeous and they all tell me i'm
beautiful and stuff but sometimes i wish
i was invis invisible
you know because i feel like that's the
only thing that they see yeah i could
see you guys both getting into trouble
yeah we
we try to stay away from that as much as
we can but
yeah it's very hard to be good-looking
and out there and
you know
they say all those guys they only want
one thing but it hurts to know that
because it's like i'm a person too you
know
how do you guys support yourselves
[Music]
we do what they say is the hustle you
know in the right ways you know i'll go
boosting if i have to i don't really
like it but
if i gotta steal from from stores i'll
steal from stores i'd rather steal from
stores than people
um
like i'd rather take from a company than
an acquaintance or you know somebody
um
but yeah that's you know i'll go to them
i'll go to my fence one of my fences and
i'll get rid of it i'll sell it
um like a product that costs a hundred
dollars i only get like 10 bucks for it
but
i grab a shitload of them and
are you the provider in the
in the family
probably yeah yeah that's a it's a noble
thing to be usually the female becomes
the money maker because yeah on the
streets you can make more money well he
can get more things to make the money
but i can make more money off of one
thing
which is like you know we both know good
things like name brands and stuff like
that as in clothes like i'll have
clothes to sell shoes to sell and i'll
sell it to like this guy like you could
see he has a nice watch on he's driving
a nice car hey do you think your wife
will like this you know
have you resorted to sex work at all no
i have never
thought about thought about making like
get go getting on a website or something
like
her making videos
yeah i don't know about that i'm a
little shy when it comes to that but
other than that i'm really outspoken and
loud and out there like what's up how
you doing
but um
yeah i
i'm not i i do tattoos too
yes he does do tattoos but
being in the street i lose
all my [ __ ] every
every every time i get it i'll have it
for a week and
as soon as you fall asleep
fall asleep and it's going everything's
yeah i have to have somebody with me all
the time you can lose your sanity as
well as your soul sometimes you know
it's i feel like i've lost my sanity so
many times
tell me what kind of
emotional strains there are of living in
the streets for you guys a lot
well recently i just went to jail i did
four months in jail and i left her to
speak alone
and that it's probably the worst thing
ever happened to me
the worst thing about every single day
in jail and like
okay well she
when would you go to jail for i went to
jail for a residential burglary
um so
then they released me to go to a program
but i didn't go to the program so now
i'm up scouting i should be in a program
which i'm not so i've got a warrant off
for my rest and
you know those bang now i'm on the run
it's only a matter of time before they
catch me and i go back in and i'm gonna
do the time but yeah every day i woke up
and i looked at the i watched the tv and
and just waited to hear her name every
morning i wake up i grabbed the
newspaper just to see if she died like
because i had no contact with her i had
no way to call her someone stole my
phone
um
and it was i had no contact with it for
four months
and that was the hardest thing ever
money what kind of
you get depressed or anxious or angry it
makes it gives me a lot of anxiety
because
before he left we our relationship
wasn't so great
um so
the way i felt was i was wasn't being
treated right you know i mean he's a
great guy he's wonderful don't get me
wrong he's amazing he's talented he's
worth it and i tell him every day you're
worth it you know you're worth living
you're worth being here and so many
people love you and adore you i adore
you
but our relationship got to a point
where it was like really bad and our and
the the verbal abuse between the both of
us was very
the emotional abuse was very bad um
so he was treating me poorly and i
probably was doing it back at him you
know because tit for tat or some reason
you know
i was hurting her people hurt people you
know um we're both hurting we're both
coming from a bad place and we're on
drugs you know that doesn't make it any
better i mean sometimes it's fun but not
always
and uh you know i just remember those
times and i couldn't be myself fully i
couldn't you know when he was
very depressed as well as i was but i
always try to make everything better you
know i always try to say okay put a
smile on my face even though i'm not
happy i don't really think i know what
happiness is
that's really all i crave these you know
these days as an adult and i don't have
my children at the time
yeah right now i don't have them so i
want to experience
as much happiness and have fun and be a
child because i never got to be a child
or a teenager
so i wanted to feel with him i feel free
but also when he went to jail i felt
free
i felt like i could be myself again and
laugh a little more but i was also very
very depressed because i know that i
could for some reason i couldn't get my
my a pen to a paper to write him a
letter and let him know that i'm
i'm waiting for him and i miss him and
all that stuff i just felt like
i was having a little bit of fun but i
really wasn't
i wasn't i was you know being tortured
and tormented by these people out there
like it was some weird stuff going on
with like the
i don't know they were just
i can't really explain it but it was
really hard being without him i missed
him every day and i
i love him the same
as the first day i met him
but it was definitely the hardest time
of being homeless with him
and it still bothers me till this day
[ __ ] happened during that time i don't
know if i can forgive her that's how
serious it is like
i needed
someone to watch over me and i had
friends watching over me but those
friendships became a little closer
being with someone having them basically
guard me because i was alone in a tent
in the back of a parking lot by a
freeway
that's kind of scary you know i had guys
there's other options that she could
have took that she didn't take for some
reason i couldn't get out of it though
it was it was it was really hard i got
stuck
you know with this drug you tend to get
stuck on stupid
let alone being stuck by a lot of people
manipulating you and taking advantage of
you
you can't i mean every guy on the street
is basically angling for one thing yes
and also um i feel like i was
like
i feel like people are trying to take me
to other places and keep me there you
know so i was scared to leave the
parking lot but i wanted to leave the
parking lot
it was it was difficult it was very
difficult in it i guess you only have to
be there and in that and experience that
for yourself to understand
you guys feel helpless against your
addictions
yeah sometimes
i feel like it's taking over completely
there's no turning back there's no way
i feel like there is hope though at the
same time i've already i've
so far now it's going on almost 16 years
getting high on heroin and fentanyl
i've been i'm i've gotten so accustomed
to this way of life like i don't know
how to live a normal life a normal life
is not a normal life that's
way out
there's no way
what do you guys worry about who are you
afraid of
i'm
i'm afraid of obvious the obvious of him
dying on me um the fentanyl is a really
hard drug you know um i was pregnant out
in the streets with him you know my
whole pregnancy and you would think that
that was the hardest time of my life
really but it really wasn't i
i i did the damn thing out there you
know i was chopping down wood you know
pallets for our fires and
carrying big logs of wood on a bike and
drinking a soda you know and i did smoke
my whole pregnancy and i did use my
whole pregnancy and
i'm not going to say i'm ashamed of it
but i'm not happy with myself and i do
beat myself up about it which i really
shouldn't because i did with what i
could with what i had you know
and like i said it's not really it's not
easy it's not what anybody thinks oh you
could just stop can't you just know it's
not that easy especially when no one
around you is like really trying so hard
to make you stop and everyone around
just doing the same thing
um
but um what was your question again
what do you fear
i feel that i'm afraid the most to walk
to go home or to go inside of a tent or
a tiny home and and see
him
pale and blue and lifeless
that's my biggest fear out here right
now
yeah it's interesting that you guys are
a couple who are doing different drugs
yeah she's down and i'm up and yeah yeah
yeah i was just i was just
asking the people we came here like you
guys both get high in the same job
like they'd be so messed up with me and
i both did this drug because it would be
expensive i think we'd go crazy
really
all bad what do you fear
i don't fear anything really
i think i've experienced everything
already and i know what's wrong actually
i fear the unknown about that yeah
that's scary
that's very scary is it difficult for
you to have given up four kids it must
be right
i feel like yeah i was a little hard in
the beginning and i did go downhill
after that um it was because of them i
went downhill a lot of people would
think
oh you're
you you he's not doing anything for you
and this is sonny and i said i made that
choice to be out here
he didn't do it he's not making me do
this drug he's not making me be out here
with him i made the choice
you know i went downhill but way before
i became homeless with him in the
streets but
it was difficult not having my children
still is difficult i haven't talked to
one of my children or seen him in three
years almost three years you know
um i have a four-year-old baby that i
don't really talk to and i was really
afraid to hear his voice change
we have a one-year-old together and
to make that decision and
to not really want to know him because
i find it easier
you know
to not have him with us
but he's with my cousin
everything's just [ __ ] up you know the
system
the way they they treat us and the way
they have us do so many things when they
know we're addicts and we have
men uh meant mentally we're not all
there you know we have to
get help and take money i think beneath
the drug addiction is a mental health
issue it is a mental health issue you
know and it goes hand in hand with
mental health you know because they put
them separate you know they categor
categorize them separately but it's all
the same [ __ ] you know we're
we got screws loose you know
i'd like to think that and um
it's hard it definitely is and it takes
a toll on you after a while
all you want to do is just forget about
everything and do more drugs
just go
partying feel free and i feel like even
partying
it's not even partying
getting doing drugs that it's not hard
just staying up and trying to go come up
you're just trying to get well
that's the difference yeah well stay up
go find things to sell and sell it and
it's like hours
10 hours can go by and it feels like you
haven't even done anything
what do you think most people that are
not drug addicts don't under understand
about addiction
[Music]
i would say oh
like my mom thinks so you can just stop
like you can just just talk when you
just and i say you don't understand you
it's not just stopping and and then the
lifestyle that you become so accustomed
to like everything that's doing anything
and everything you want not having
responsibility to pay bills and stuff
like that they don't understand that you
become free in a certain sense is it
scary would it be scary for you to live
a square life
yeah
i don't know
that's the school the normal life i i
don't know what that's about right now
yeah it's been a long time for you um
i was the caretaker of my family my
children my you know my ex-boyfriends
and stuff you know
what they say wore the pants often
but um
it is a little bit scary because i'm
i've adjusted to this lifestyle and i'm
comfortable
and it's sad a little bit because i i
had everything i had my
i was renting houses apartments i had
cars i had
money saved bank accounts you know now i
don't even have a
how do you call that a cash app card to
for someone to send me money it's like
not normal
you know you don't even keep a phone out
here when i fall asleep my phone goes
missing and that's scary in itself
you know to know that someone reached
their tiny stupid little hands in my
tent and took my phone um
that and
a lot of other things that are
yours but they haven't done the drug my
my parents have never gotten high my mom
so she doesn't even know how that feels
i feel like if someone would feel the
high that that
that that drug gives you like you know i
feel like you would fall in love with it
it's like a rockstar lifestyle without
the money
drugs and sex and rock and roll yeah
it's it's fun sometimes
sometimes it's really not fun it gets
out of hands it all starts off cool and
then everyone just starts
falling apart and everyone starts by
himself and everyone just starts like
dying there's genuine people
and then there's people that are just
out
you know for their own everyone is
to reach his own right a lot of snakes a
lot of snakes in the grass of
california the sunniest place for the
shadiest people i hate california
yeah i'm from here and i and i can't
seem to have like one
good friend no i think once drug
addiction comes into the picture it
changes
everybody yeah there's there's good
people here there's good people
everywhere yeah and but a lot of the
people that you have in your life like
the good people they start thinking
poorly of you um like you're gonna steal
from them or you're gonna i don't
believe in the stealing thing
i mean i'm not gonna say that i haven't
recently
not really really stupid like taking
stuff from friends because like how does
it feel but i still have it here you go
don't be a jerk and don't ever take from
me again you know or i'm gonna start
taking from you because the one you
don't think is going to do it will
eventually because you
but the stealing thing from each other
is [ __ ] you know because you're
taking you're going to be taking
something
so precious and valuable to that other
person and it really sucks when you do
lose everything because not only have we
lost storages but we've lost
everything and then lately it's been
multiple times i've lost everything in a
shopping cart
what are your regrets
do you have regrets
i have regrets yeah
i regret relapsing this recent time when
i had my first child i regret relapsing
when he was four months it
was really really
it really tore me out don't
before i came to california and one of
my best friends says california's either
going to make you or break you bro he
cheered up two yeah
cool and like you know
it was making me he was making me he was
making me i was i was becoming somebody
i was becoming a tattoo artist becoming
the person i wanted to be
and this one fool came to my house
um to get a tattoo and he brought some
heroin
and i was clean and i'm like oh [ __ ]
like
i haven't like been in this position
before where someone came with some [ __ ]
like my drug
and so like
my son was four months old and
i ended up i ended up getting high i
couldn't say no to it i couldn't say no
um it was a
it was really messed up it was really
messed up dude
yeah
yeah yeah i regret that i regret that
i regret
listening to other people's [ __ ] and
believing lies and and having it turn
out for the worst for myself because i
believed what someone said once and i
it ended up going into me overdosing i
found some drugs in the dirt you know i
was really angry at this when throwing
his stuff in the middle of the street
tearing up his tent with a knife cutting
it open
i got tired so i was like oh i remember
i found this little sack in the dirt
so i ended up hot reeling the whole bag
and it was fentanyl and i didn't know i
didn't even know what fentanyl looked
like at the time
and i was i didn't know i was like two
months pregnant at at that time as well
and um
i overdosed and i went out and i was
dead maybe for about five minutes five
and a half minutes and they were just
waiting for that six minute for me to
start shutting down and
take me in
but at five and a half minutes i woke up
but before that i saw me and my my kids
in bed after a shower and i finally you
know i laid down and said finally
and i heard
slow down three times
and i woke up
i regret believing other people i regret
going against the love of my life my
best friend all because someone told her
i was with some girl at a hotel it never
happened
and she believed it and went and did
that and my regrets are just going
against every everything that he said
and it's like i told you so like a slap
in the face you know like i should have
listened
people on the street will say anything
to to get to her and i'm very vulnerable
and very weak sometimes and they i think
you could see it all over my face when
that happens because
every time i've been weak and vulnerable
at something stupid
i let some stupid idiot come into my
life whether it's a man or woman in
takeover you know it's pretty shitty
sometimes i'm too nice
but my heart's so big i want to help
everyone and i want to
help the homeless and i want to help the
youth and i just i want to help so bad
but i can't help everyone because when
it's time for me
who's going to be there you know and the
one that i expect to be the most and
will be there for me no matter what
i i would have heard him by then you
know and
it sucks
what would you guys say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
lives
money and all that stuff way up there
is not everything
um
[Music]
i've learned to
man
it's not the quality of things it's the
not the quantity of things it's the
quality
and then i don't know i just
i guess
i guess
you're still learning yeah
yeah we're still learning and you know
like i said the quantity and quality of
things it's
it doesn't matter if most of the time
we've been together he's been terrible
or or how many times you know the good
and the bad outweigh each other but
this one time you know i had given birth
to our son and i'm in the hospital and i
woke up with this quiet t-shirt laying
on top of me
and my nails were painted and my makeup
was done and i've got to say no matter i
don't care how much someone has done
what a guy has done for me in my life
how much money the guy has whatever the
hell
i'd rather be homeless in the street
with this one and had and woken up to
that
after giving birth it was the cutest
thing i've ever
the most precious thing i've ever seen
in my life you know i'll never forget
that
all right monique and kyle thank you so
much for sharing thank you
good luck with you guys thank you so
much
you